[Musique]
c'est un mercenaire international et en
fait quand on ne sculpt un peu la vie de
ces gens il y a une grande solitude il y
a des choix moraux très compliqués à
faire forcément quand on a vraiment
regardé ce qui se passe derrière le
derrière le rideau et qu'on se rend
compte de ce qui est vraiment la
politique internationale on a une vision
du monde qui est forcément très sombre
et extrêmement cynique
j'avais quelqu'un de puis 5 ans et on va
se marier
[Musique]
ce qui est intéressant c'est que en fait
on ne le voit pas que en tant que
personnel on le voit aussi en train de
se débattre avec une histoire d'amour
dans laquelle il souffre énormément donc
je pense que le fait qu'on est cette
double vision sur le personnage tel
qu'on le voit courir tabasser des gens
mais qu'à côté de ça on le voit avec une
teinte de coeur dont il n'arrive pas à
se soigner je crois que c'est ça qui
fait ressortir son humanité
c'était à la hauteur de mes attentes et
de mes espoirs mais ce que j'ai
découvert avec le temps c'est qu'en fait
cette attraction que j'avais pour elle
en tant qu'actrice c'est parce que je la
trouve très particulière et qu'en fait
je me reconnais moi-même dans cette
partie
je me suis toujours un peu vu comme ça
comme un avec un peu comme un outsider
un peu différent d'ailleurs on a souvent
reproché au début de ma carrière et je
la vois comme ça je trouve qu'elle
ressemble à aucune autre actrice et
quand je dis ça c'est un compliment bien
sûr que je me fais
[Musique]